بعد انتهاء الحرب العالميه الثانيه ساعه
اوروبا للملمه جراحها نشات فكره السوق
الاوروبيه المشتركه بقيت الفكره تتطور
وتتسع حتى عام 93 نضجت التجربه اكثر بعد
قمه كوبنهاجن التي ارست شروط الانضمام
للاتحاد الذي لا يزال يتوسع ويضم دولا
جديده يضم الاتحاد الاوروبي اليوم 28 دوله
وعلى المنظمين الجدد تحقيق شروط اساسيه
شروط سياسيه تفرض على المترشح ضمان مؤسسات
ديمقراطيه تحترم حقوق الانسان وتكافح
الفساد شروط اقتصاديه بحيث تعتمد الدوله
المترشحه على نظام اقتصادي يعتمد على
اقتصاد السوق وقادر على التعامل مع
المنافسه بالاضافه الى شروط تشريعيه اذ
تستعد الدوله المترشحه لتعديل تشريعاتها
بما يتناسب مع التشريعات والقيم الاوروبيه
بناء على تلك الشروط تبدا اجراءات
الانضمام للات تبدا بتقديم طلب الترشح اذ
يمكن لاي دوله اوروبيه التقدم بطلب للحصول
على عضويه الاتحاد اخر المتقدمين اوكرانيا
صيف العام الماضي تدخل المرحله المسماه
باستراتيجيه ما قبل الانضمام هي عباره عن
برنامج تستوفي من خلاله الدوله عددا من
الاصلاحات حتى تتوافق مع تشريعات وقوانين
الاتحاد ثم تبدا مرحله المفاوضات وهنا
يجري التاكد من قدره الدوله على تحقيق
شروط الانضمام مثل استقرار العمليه
الديمقراطيه والسوق ما زالت دول عديده
عالقه في هذه المرحله منها تركيا منذ عام
99 وصربيا منذ عام 2009 عند اجتياز تلك
المرحله ونجاح المفاوضات يرتب توقيع
المعاهده بتقديمها الى الدول الاعضاء
والبرلمان الاوروبيه اخيرا يجري التصديق
على الانضمام بموافقه جميع دول الاتحاد
ويحدث ان تجري بعض الدول استفتاء شعبيا
على ذلك كما ذكرنا فقد تقدمت اوكر الصيف
الماضي بطلب الانضمام هي تامل ان تنهي
الاجراءات خلال العامين المقبلين فسالون
اوروبيون يشككون في واقعيه الطموحات
الاوكرانيه يقول الرئيس الفرنسي ان انضمام
اوكرانيا ربما يستغرق عقوده لماذا ستكون
اوكرانيا الدوله الافقر في الاتحاد وستزيد
فاتوره اعاده الاعمار من ذلك الفقر يهدد
الفساد انضمام اوكرانيا كذلك اذ تصنف ثاني
اكثر الدول فسادا في القاره لذلك استبقت
القمه الاوروبيه الاوكرانيه بحمله
اعتقالات طالت مسؤولين كثر تحت شعار
مكافحه الفساد اكدت تقف اوكرانيا على عدم
الاتحاد الاوروبي سرعت حرب روسيا من خطوات
اوكرانيا نحو الاتحاد لكنه يطلب المزيد
ولا يبدو الامر قريب المنهل